[Musique]
stress et enthousiasme se confondent et
pour la centaine de chefs d'entreprises
qui participent à ce speed casting
l'objectif est de sélectionner quatorze
finalistes répartis dans sept catégories
c'est la mission des membres du réseau
point chance chambres consulaires
associations d'accompagnement la
création d'entreprise financeurs ou
encore expert comptable tous mobilisés
pour l'entrepreneuriat andré encore
valorisé plus ces personnes là et comme
je leur disais il eu faty soit la hérie
discutent entre eux de chacun leur
activité ça donne des idées à d'autres
et puis ils vont faire passer aussi
cette parole du travail du 2 2 7
conscience professionnelle qu'ils ont
c'est aujourd'hui c'est important de
s'accrocher à des projets comme ça parce
que ça leur permet vraiment d'évoluer au
niveau de la famille au niveau des amis
tout ça ça donne une valeur personnelle
et une conscience professionnelle c'est
c'est malheureusement
il faut qu'on arrive à encore plus de
résultats comme ça mais c'est déjà un
grand pas après huit minutes pour
convaincre les finalistes sont choisis
par catégorie insertion création
d'emplois performance innovation
produits péi start up et prix du jury
une variété de catégories qui donne une
chance à tout le monde
pour moi c'est la consécration la
consécration de du commun de cinq ans de
travail et les soutiens ma famille tout
cela est aujourd'hui bien c'est au moins
ça paye c'est pour moi c'est comme si un
grand prix on aujourd'hui c'est honnête
tout est mieux je pense que non en fait
je trouve que on est plus d'une centaine
à avoir participé postuler on est tous
créateurs d'entreprises déjà d'avoir
passé deux journées
entouré de créateurs d'entreprise qui
comme nous vivent la même chose en fait
et de voir que tout le monde vit la même
chose c'est c'est eh voilà c'est vrai
que ça conforte les reportages télévisés
vous permettront de découvrir bientôt
ses quatorze finalistes
une manière de présenter l'insertion
professionnelle durable de ces personnes
qui se sont pris en main